this is Meg Amy Beth and Joe my girls  have a way of getting into mischief oh I  know thank me you're the only sane man  we've got troublemaking family I want to  be great or nothing mefist a shy girl I  wish is to having us all to be together  about this perfect Joe would you like to  dance with me Joe is a lost cause I  intend to make my own way in the world  and Meg thank you I'm much I want a home  and a family  don't leave you'll be bored of him in  two years and we will be interesting  forever  women have minds and they have souls as  well as just hearts  you're not angry at me life is too short  to be angry at one sisters  [Music]  where'd you get the money I only sold  what was my own you do a witty PG  you